alors que la barre symbolique des cent
mille morts de la commune 19 vient
d'être dépassée en france c'était un cap
redouté nous avons officiellement passé
la barre des 100000 morts
la troisième vague continue de sévir
partout dans le pays avec des hôpitaux
encore bondée des services réanimation
toujours plus saturé nous sommes dans
une période de l'épidémie de la pandémie
extrêmement dangereuse le chef de l'état
a présidé jeudi soir une réunion pour
examiner le protocole de déconfinement
et de réouverture des lieux publics que
les français attendent temps si partout
à travers le monde les pays allègent
leurs restrictions sanitaires comme ce
week-end à londres où des scènes de
liesse populaire avait lieu ou encore en
israël où le port du masque en extérieur
a été levée ce dimanche en france cette
liberté totale semble encore bien loin
car certains estiment qu'il faut encore
être prudent
nous avons encore devant nous des jours
très difficiles
pourtant d'autres appellent à revenir à
une vie d'avant nous sommes prêts il
faut rouvrir maintenant alors faut-il
tout rouvrir ce soir le conseiller
régional grand et florian philippot fait
face à stefan mani goal sur notre
plateau
est on avec nous ses fans manigold merci
stéphane d'être avec nous merci on à
florian philippot merci d'être là
également furent soir nouveau président
des patriotes et qui écrit un bouquin la
grande bascule kobe 19 la grande bascule
merci d'être là florian philippot ses
fans manigold propriétaires de
restaurants à paris et jean paul hamon
médecin merci d'être là à palmeiras
toujours un bonheur de vous avoir merci
à vous et 3 alors florian philippot oui
il faut tout rouvrir stefan mani goal il
ne faut pas tout rouvrir du jour au
lendemain seulement les terrasses et
jean paul hamon le médecin et c'est ça
qui me fait peur non
il faut tout laisser faire mais vous
allez nous dire pourquoi dans un instant
tout de ravoir la vie à bord de de
l'équipe gilles verdez pour vous non non
rien pour moi il faut rien ouvrir je le
dise pourquoi c'est une folie on n'est
pas prêt au chili ils ont rouvert
maintenant il ya des contamination
massive
il faut laisser fermée jusqu'à ce qu'il
n'y ait plus de circulation du virus est
que tout le monde soit vacciné les sont
fermés alors que laurence mais ils
exagèrent on va pas laisser fermer
toutes les circulations non mais non
aujourd'hui on n'a pas tous rouvrir d'un
coup c'est la nuance mais bien sûr qu'il
va falloir commencer à ouvrir au mois de
mai tout doucement et de manière
progressive
on peut pas dire qu'on peut pas tout
rouvrir imaginer là les gens n'en
peuvent plus et à un moment vous allez
avoir plus de morts si vous voulez
d'autres choses donc bien sûr que c'est
pas tout rouvrir d'un coup comme veulent
défendre à notre ami qui est venue de
florian philippot il lui et devrait tour
ouvrir depuis un an
d'ailleurs là nous dire pour moi n'a
rien à ses idées
voilà bien sûr mais là il me dit qu'on
avait découvert le oui mais non on ne
sait pas qui est dans le vrai et je vous
dirai pour l'instant on sait pas qui a
remis à ferran fera les comptes plus
tard parce que les jeux les donneurs de
leçons s'il va pas tourner aujourd'hui
évidemment ce serait impossible et ça
serait mettre en l'air tous les efforts
qu'on a faits depuis un an vous
guillaume alors en fait c'est simple ça
fait un an qu'on est dans cette
situation qui est invivable et en fait
malgré les vaccins malgré le confinement
et malgré les gestes barrière absolument
rien n'a changé on est toujours au même
état souvenez vous fin 2020 emmanuel
macron avait dit vous rendez compte si
on rouvre tout va y avoir des centaines
de milliers de morts balle en fait c'est
la double peine
il ya cent mille morts et on peut plus
rien faire depuis un an dont les
variantes étaient
avant et accepter que le coc vide est un
virus comme un autre qui tuent des
milliers de gens alors florian philippot
pour vous il faut tout ouvrir
bah oui parce que le soleil a pas deux
il n'y a pas de lien entre c'est ça
qu'il faut sortir de la tête des gens
n'y a pas de lien entre les restrictions
de liberté les couvre-feux les
confinements les fermetures et la
dynamique d'une épidémie c'est pas ça
une politique de santé publique
petit guide santé publique c'est prendre
sereinement les choses sur la prévention
le système immunitaire le traitement
quel énorme tabou a vraiment à mon avis
derrière il ya des preuves de corruption
d'ailleurs les traitements qui sont pas
autorisés conférence un master que vous
avez des traitements comme la
chloroquine par les citoyens l'euro qui
n'hésiteront micinn l'ivermectine vous
avec 40 étudiants un article de capital
là qui est sorti un mois c'est pas la
gazette des patriotes qui disent quoi
qu'il dise que c'est 40 études dont 20
en double aveugle qui montrent que c'est
extrêmement efficace et des pays qui
l'utilisent le portugal en ce moment
l'utilisent alors on va s'arrêter deux
secondes là dessus parce qu'on a on a un
exemple pour expliquer relance et
peut-être de débat il ya le 10 mars le
texas qui est le deuxième état le plus
peuplé des états unis en mai le
mississippi c'est pareil tout rouvre
tout à son nouveau tout et on enlève le
masque obligatoire
les gens qui veulent le mettre il omet
mais c'est pas obligatoire et un support
by john dit ça va être
c'est une erreur fatale je le cite c'est
une décision néandertalienne c'est à
dire un peu arriérés bon je suis la
bonne expression ultra courant je
connais moins un mois et demi plus tard
les contaminations sont en baisse
c'était à la est bien mieux en mieux
positionné parmi les états américains
donc en fait il fallait ils ont même
fait 38 mille spectateurs ou pour le
baseball dans un stade là le 6 avril bah
il faut arrêter ce délire
et sinon on va tous tués dans le pays
selon on va tuer non seulement les
restaurateurs les commerces mais la vie
la vie démocratique la liberté la
psychologie la morale l'économie enfin
la morale des le moral des gens là
dessus dans un instant c'était pas de
made in gold à vous répondre je sais que
stéphane déjà en un mot c'est qu'on
n'est pas d'accord avec florian
philippot non je suis pas d'accord avec
les incantations flanc filipe luis mizon
de bougies un peu comme certains
politiques
il fait de l'incantation la vraie vie ça
ne les connaissez pas certain mais que
moi c'est pour les marseillais
je veux dire me suis dit je vais vous
répondre restons ouverts vous
oui bah oui on va y arriver bachand vous
inquiétez pas donc vous vous êtes dans
l'incantation vous faites de la
politique
moi je suis un chef d'entreprise vous
vous n'avez jamais travaillé de votre
vie donc forcer le jeu si vous voulez
entendre de ma part oui faut tout ouvrir
demain
factuellement je vous répondrais oui
mais la vérité c'est quand on est chef
d'entreprise
nos agriculteurs eh ben il faut qu'ils
reproduisent un peu pour alimenter
l'ensemble des restaurants faut qu'on
fasse venir nos salariés pourquoi leur
forme
parce que nous on fait pas juste de
l'incantation ont fait de la cuisine
quoi on est des artisans monsieur fier
de le dire dans s'offrir c'est prévu ça
y est c'est qu'en attendez-vous ce que
vous faites c'est de la politique des
croyants personnalités sur la politique
de la montre cassé c'est à dire que mon
cas c'est même une honte cassiel donnent
leurs deux fois par jour juste ça nous a
donné cette crise a de longues heures et
bresson bon florian philippot coville 19
la grande bascule c'est son livre et
florian philippot pense qu'il faut tout
pour ouvrir jean paul hamon médecins non
il faut tout laisser fermer et mon jean
paul pendant la pause là il m'a dit
cyril passe moi le ballon parce que là
il faut que j'aille là je suis pas bien
qu'est ce qui se passe me jean-paul
écoutez moi le lors du premier
confinement j'ai été le premier à dire
qu'il fallait rouvrir les plages les
parts que les forêts parce que c'était
une connerie de tout laisser fermer mais
là on à 5900 personnes en réanimation et
ça grimpe d'accord vouloir dire qu'il
faut tout rouvrir
ça c'est vraiment de la folie pure c'est
de la provocation c'est vraiment aller
racler les fonds de tiroir essayé de
ramasser les complotistes parce qu'il ya
des élections etc
il ya un moment il faut arrêter de
déconner quoi hein moi je suis pour
qu'on retrouve les terrasses les
terrasses je suis pour qu'on trouve les
musées au tiers des magasins puisque lé
magasin 2e mine de rien de vêtements
pariente dans des dents des je vous dis
le jean paul ii disait là dans la fois
un magasin de vêtements dans une petite
ville ou dans des villes où la même
normal y voit là franchement c'est pas
cinquante personnes dans les magasins
moi j'ai ça fait maintenant deux mois
que qu'olivier ferrand c'est le cabinet
de 15,6 et que
il ya des purificateurs d'air qui
détruisent au virus détruisent de virus
les magasins brick et à nantes
personne personne du gouvernement est
allé vérifier ça or ça sécuriserait sa
sécuriserait des classes parce que ça
pue reeves illégal savaria purifient
l'air vissi m² deux mètres cinquante de
hauteur
anna sécuriserait les classes ça
sécuriserait les petits commerces ça
pourrait même peut-être ouvrir des
restaurants
ça coûte d'accord un gros seins ça coûte
ça coûte 1500 euros là mais c'est bien
moins cher que c'est un appel à ceux qui
ont fait ça est ce qui peut venir 2 -
demain on témoin du jour pour qui nous
en parle et pour qu'on fasse un appel au
gouvernement demain avec eux dans
l'émission en direct parce que ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est un truc ce n'est pas
donc ça y est j'y lis on va devenir
demain quand on peut installer ils sont
venus nous installer dans mon cabinet la
semaine dernière ils sont bien installés
dans mon cabinet la semaine dernière et
ils sont en train de fabriquer des
petits boîtiers de 15,15 qu'on peut
poser sur une table qui sécurise sur une
surface de 15 mètres carrés et tout ça
et sur un volume de 2 500
je savais pas voilà le gouvernement n'a
pas bougé parce qu'il dit les
purificateurs d'air ça ne marche pas or
is aspire l'air et ils détruisent le
virus par paris peroxydation dans le
boîtier et c'est complètement différent
d'un signal wifi catr d'air qu'on peut
avoir
ça fait deux mois que le gouvernement le
sait et il ne bouge pas c'est ça qui me
rend furax d'un accord
voilà c'est là bas tu as raison il a
fallu vraiment gueuler comme des veaux
pour obtenir le droit de faire cette
dose avec les faiseurs alors qu'on était
capables qui avait aucune différence
entre la première et la 7e doses il a
fallu gueuler pour le faire mais ce cas
pour l'obtenir a le droit de le faire et
un droit de l'injecter alors qu' aucune
différence entre la première à l'essai
tim dowse et là sur les purificateurs
d'air c'est pareil mais dire qu'il faut
tout ouvrir ça pour moi c'est criminel
les réalisations sont pleines monsieur
philippe au canton est temps d'y revenir
depuis une voiture
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
choisisse à mesa tolérer animateurs que
les réanimateurs soit nommé attend de
lui un des leurs et lima mais la
situation de choisir qui vont rénover ou
pas mais sciemment
regardez ça vous regarde et savez comme
nous en norvège 60 ans il a fait un
rassemblement comme vous sans masque 1
c'était un complotiste
il est mort de la commission d'accord on
a continué comme ça c'est bien vous
m'aviez dit l'autre soir il aurait fini
pour fermer assez de lits à l'hôpital
vous êtes toujours d'accord sur le fait
mais je suis je suis d'accord vous pour
je me souviens que c'est parce que l'art
la réforme des systèmes de santé n'a pas
n'a pas eu lieu
là les hôpitaux les habitants de savoir
à ses personnels
or ce les ennemis sont donc vous à dire
sur 20 km avant pour toi pourquoi n'y a
pas cet affront mais lorsqu'on occupe
les hospitaliers parce qu'on occupe les
hospitaliers à des à des fonctions qui
pourraient être faites en ville bien
moins cher c'est à dire qu'on surveille
des maladies chroniques qui sont
inclinés voulait fermer des l'on fait
des écoles de l'asthme ont fait des
écoles de l'asthme et ce personnel là il
serait bien plus utile dans les services
il se passe quelque chose en saône et
loire je crois ou là on vient de mettre
des paramédicaux dans les ambulances de
réanimation c'est à dire des gens qui
sont capables d'amener en moins de vingt
minutes les gens à l'hôpital
là où il ya des vrais services d'urgence
si à paris aussi dans toutes les grandes
agglomérations
cyril si dans toutes les grandes
agglomérations où on est à moins de 20
minutes d'un vrai service d'urgence des
paramédics qui sont formés qui
transporte le type et qui l'amène à
l'hosto en moins de vingt minutes
imaginez le nombre de réanimateurs qui
serait seulement dans les services
hospitaliers
voilà ce qu'il faut à la vraie réforme
mais c'est classieux vraie compassion le
débat faut-il faire bondir sur ce qu'il
a dit à ce sujet la wii alors justement
on reste là dessus ce sont vos sources
pour dire qu'il y ait un lien entre la
fermeture et l'épidémie parce que là si
ça veut dire que j'avais tout vous avez
moins de radoter ne vient pas de là
il ya pas de lien c'est vous qui
attendez je vais laisser mes cv
la suède n'a jamais fermé aujourd'hui à
15 % de morts par habitant en moins que
nous sans avoir détruit le fossé c'est
vrai ça y est il ya 15 % de morts en
moins par habitant en suède qu'en france
ils n'ont jamais fermé ils n'ont jamais
fermé aux restaurants salles de sport
sont jamais très finement plus fort à la
fois sur la grèce et avant devaient
changer ça n'est pas si vieira sait mais
n'est pas les chiffres mais je connais
les suédois images de manière semi
ancien mexique à cheval car s'il ya deux
mois la russie à tour ouvert aujourd'hui
à pas du tout d'explosion je vous ai
parlé du texas du mississippi
donc en fait vous faites de la pseudo
science du charlatanisme et vous
détruisez des médias samara ouvrir s'il
vous plaît mais florian philippot il est
dangereux d art et nature
il parle à un espèce d'électorat qu'on
peut tisser là je rejoins docteur ramon
pourquoi parce que je parle parce que
vous aimez pas aller dans le rouge en
plein dont james vous aidant les
punchline et des invectives
mais en valais dans le fond on a eu un
débat fort tous les deux sur le
passeport sanitaires et le qr code
je vous annonçais jeu mais je mets joue
oui j'ai des ponts le dialogue et je
vous annonce un truck series sur notre
plateau droit dans les yeux le qr code
dans la enterré parce qu'on accepte et
contrairement à vous de participer au
débat
il n'y aura pas de chair code le 15 mai
j'ai rendu rendu la bouche dans les
nuages malvy je le vis bas il dit il y
aura plus de droit
enterré parce que contrairement à vous
très hydro de vie dans les soeurs ma
chronique je vous le dis mélenchon mais
non je vais discuter avec jean françaix
raison de région lui discuté ce que jack
avec eux note au 6e rang mais c'est avec
votre aide je vais discuter avec les
maires de mon arrondissement je vais
discuter que les adjoints je vais
discuter que les scientifiques disent le
contraire fait chier tout le monde moi
je deviens le jury traverse ouvert je
suis qui n'est pas votre cas on obtient
des résultats parce qu'on est dans le
dialogue
je suis comme ça qu'on fait cette
famille on est capable de détruire voilà
on détruit rouge vous êtes dans l'ain
victime j'ai pas quoi et monsieur pas
dans le fond monsieur et je vous ai dit
j'ai un kit pour les nuls parce qu'il
serait temps de mettre à jour un enjeu
très content mais c'est vrai que les
louages jour sur vos références et
fanatisme et stéphanie des fans de danse
et le passeport salutaire hier mettez
vous à jour monsieur mais c'est quand
même mal informés et référencer vos
frères annoncé au salon ce sujet aura
contre cette année ni pau ne vont pas le
faire le qr code de cheveux lissés sur
un côté du vaccin astrazeneca dans un
super congélateur hiver a pu arriver à
plus chauds concernant le patient s'est
banalisé drôles de noëls son passe-temps
sanitaires j'ai des potes restaurateurs
hâter la ville j'ai des potes l'ancien
chauffeur tchadien
ça marche pas personne le nombre c'est
une lubie alors vous agiter les peurs et
nous c'est ce qu'on met juste vraiment
bien fait besoin de manille goal on a
envie un peu de loin on aimerait savoir
ce qui va se passer là il ya plein de
gens qui nous regardent ya des
téléspectateurs qui ont envie de savoir
des restaurateurs des gens à l'action
dans le commerce des gens qui ont envie
aussi de 2,2 de savoir si les terrasses
vont rouvrir ce qui va se passer cet été
quel est le calendrier je sais que vous
avez des infos est-ce que les
terrassements rouvrir me met fin mai
début mais qu'est ce qui va se passer
oui me mais nous ouvrons c'est pourquoi
pas céder le gouvernement vous a dit le
mime et vous allez ouvrir cet été
seulement will & grace
d'accord pas parce que factuellement
c'est pas mais chic c'est le chiffre de
santé publique france 2 10% des
contaminations se font à l'extérieur
d'accord à l'évidence il faut qu'on
avait l'extérieur et je vais même vous
donner un deuxième secousse mais qui est
pas ma chronique comme munich qui juste
du bon sens basket dirigeant
d'entreprise c'est prévoir aussi et
j'anticipe le président république et
l'annoncé qui prendra la parole trois
semaines avant je vous faire un scoop
s'il tient sa parole il prend la parole
jeudi et jeudi il
11 et jeudi ils annoncent l'ouverture mi
mai donc oui alors jeudi le président de
la république devrait prendre
apparemment oui si on oublie mais ils
vont prévenir mes mains mais c'est juste
factuelle en mon travail ce que je pense
d'eux on été choisi c'est sûr je suis
dit néanmoins falloir en janvier je
crois sur le même plateau vous aviez dit
on va faire le confinement je vous
l'annonçais ya pas eu le confinement
janvier donc vos sources faut quand même
les revoir malheureusement le qr code
oui attal malraux l'ont annoncé et
l'union européenne est en train de le
nôtre alors l ouverture sanitaires sur
l'ouverture la réouverture vous ne
m'avez toujours pas donner d'arguments
scientifiques pour m'expliquer le lien
entre ces restrictions et ces fermetures
et l'épidémie parce que ça n'a rien à
voir mais il est la raison scientifique
moi je suis moi je suis alors laissé
laissez-nous vous répondent non à
l'arrivée du rennais là dessus on a un
point d'accord on a un point leur jeu
comme le souligne ça fait un an que je
parle des purificateurs d'air notamment
dans les salles de classe ça fait un an
qu effectivement vers on n'en parle pas
et ne le relève même pas et ça je ne
comprends pas et j'espère que vous aurez
plus de succès que moi j'attendrais la
philharmonie de l'avarié et enchaîne les
chiffres de la suède
donc c'est 1354 morts par million
d'habitants la france 1504 donc c'est
bien qu'adam sait trop s'il vous plaît
ses 625 la semaine dernière pour la
suède
191 l'auto là les chéris c'est très
intéressant mais ce n'est pas le débat
c'est très juste
répondre ailleurs aux séries mais il n'y
a aucun lien entre les lits et
l'épidémie le clan le problème le
problème actuellement c'est qu'on a
fermé des lits hospitaliers mais on n'a
pas fait la réforme du système de santé
on n'a pas mis les moyens sur la ville
pour éviter les hospitalisations et
raccourcir les hospitalisations
parce que c'est tout un système là
actuellement olivier ferrand a fait un
ségur qui est insécure de l'hôpital et
pains ségur de la santé le système de
santé doit marcher sur ses deux jambes
et si l'hôpital veut être soulagés 1 on
occupe à son personnel dans des dents
des tâches qui pourrait être faite
facilement en ville et moins cher et
deux on est vite on donne les moyens
l'hôpital à la ville d'éviter des
hospitalisations avec des équipes de
l'infirmier le médecin anglais le
voulait écrire librement
attendez attendez pas le coup de
l'ivermectine il ya quand même une étude
qui a été faite le jama kyi qui n'a
aucun conflit d'intérêt avec le v6 qui
sont regrettables qui montrent que ça
sert à que d'un vrai meeting ça vous
fait pas de mal mais de toute façon ça
raccourci rapport les hospitalisations
et les syndicats les imitera pas voilà
le vrai sujet c'est parce que vous êtes
patriotes mais par pardonnez moi je
trouve que vous dites un peu n'importe
quoi parce qu'il me sens malgré tout que
l'année dernière il ya un an on a été
confiné d'une manière relativement
strictes vous êtes d'accord
et ça a fonctionné mais en suède il
était pas j'aimerais qu'on arrête de
parler de la suède deux ont passé la
dernière fois
c'est s'ouvrir à 200 addict à comme ça
il a une fiction voilà les livres aller
chéri j'ai pas envie qu'on parle du
passé j'ai envie qu'on parle de la wii
donc juste je suis où link est ce qui va
se passer
moi je regarde juste aujourd'hui
l'angleterre et israël cm2 fixette je
voudrais absolument savoir si ça marche
parce que ils ont fait l'un
progressivement intelligemment
il ouvre petit à petit les terrasses
avec des restrictions sanitaires avec de
l'ordre et voilà moi je regarde et je
prie et je sais ce qu'on va faire rire
je serais d'accord ils ont maxine et ils
ont indiqué dans des cas mais on peut
aller en angleterre cet après-midi le
ried jeunes seuls deux minutes non mais
c'est ça le mieux le coup de la
l'angleterre c'est la vaccination et la
vaccination massive de la population
là actuellement effectivement l'astra
zeneca du plomb dans l aile la restreint
et n'est qu'à l'est les cas de thrombose
sais c'est un cas pour cent cinquante
mille personnes
d'accord les femmes qui prennent une
contraception elles ont quatre cas de
thrombose pour dix mille femmes qui
prennent la pilule est ce qu'on a retiré
la pilule de la 2de du commerce n'ont
donc c'est ça le problème si vous voulez
un cas sur cent cinquante mille il faut
se vacciner les plus de 55 ans il faut
se vaccine and girls astrazeneca
il faut se vacciner massivement la seule
façon de vivre
la seule façon de revivre normalement
c'est de se vacciner c'est le saut
vacciner massivement c'est tout si alors
oui qu'est ce que voulait dire
magnifique ça voulait dire le royaume
uni voilà ce qu'on attend voilà ce que
les français et françaises ça c'est
quand pour les français je dois me met
15 mai son vous attendiez il faut se
rappeler vous on dit quoi dit la vérité
il ya 14 et le 17
voilà 34 ans et camille serme n 17 mais
on se retrouve alors à toute la france
subit en france partout en france
quinze jours après ouverture à moins
qu'ils aient c'est quoi alors leurs
lauriers dit non alors quinze jours
après ouverture de l'intérêt avec une
jauge à 50%
il craint jours après on redit tous
normalement comme je suis
faut faire gaffe faut pas que ce soit la
fête du slip quand même parce que là
tout le plateau le plateau de
contamination en réanimation il est
vachement il veut c'est ça donc si tu
veux on va rouvrir
on va vivre dehors on va maintenir
l'existant des barrières dehors on va
vacciner etc
on va commencer à lever le truc et et au
mois de septembre on aura maxime
lévesque info on arabe accès non nommés
mais moi j'ai pas d'infos là dessus mais
si tu sais ce qu'il faut faire
or on sait qu'on va vacciner sans c'est
qu'on va voir davantage de vaccins et
que dc dc mois de septembre on aura
vacciner allez on va dire les la moitié
de la population et qui s'étaient
pacsées castaldi conquest racing avec un
jean paul ben moi j'ai eu droit ou
pfizer parce que j'aime pas les
soignants en valais vous pourrez lire
philippot n'ont pas été vaccinés vous
allez vous faire vacciner c'est pas
prévu non pas c'est la question piège
vous donne un astre à zenica bourbon
s'attend pas à ce trajet mais qu'a vécu
au danemark je suis l'autorité danoise
qu'il l'a interdit quand vous signale
qu'il est pas autorisé aux états unis au
jeune margot ouais je ne savais pas
comme le savent les douze celui-ci admet
que cela vient aussi d'ailleurs la suède
parce que j'en ai profité bon monsieur
hamon moi je ne fais pas de lien la
liberté c'est un absolu
donc ça arrête conditionnée à une
vaccination ou quoi que ce soit première
non deuxièmement méfiez vous parce que
chili dont vacciner à fond bon courage à
ces pensent ils viennent leur confier
des clochards les magasins et troisième
manche et n'avait qu'un mois
troisièmement vous nous dit les attend
ils on va nous dire quoi le chilien et
cantine et 50%
vous nous dites il faudra vérifier mais
peu importe je vous nous dites la
vaccination c'est la solution sepa geely
cette gamme marque
troisièmement je comprends pas qu'un
médecin se bat pas pour le serment
d'hippocrate ses terres la prévention et
le traitement c'est çà ou là vous
devriez vous battre pas pour enrichir
l'industrie pharmaceutique
mille morts malheureusement ils sont
sûrs et des restrictions vous ne m'avez
toujours pas démontré en quoi c'était
utile de fermer puisque les pays qui ne
l'ont pas fait ont les mêmes résultats
voire meilleure que la fera alors ça
c'est de la science et sur l'actuelle
aussi la suède ou la suède
effectivement a affirmé beaucoup plus
tard que nous
maintenant les gens effectivement en
suède se promener dans la rue sans
masque et ses bas et c'est vrai aussi
qu'à l'extérieur qui ont en cours assez
peu de risques on a toujours dit qu'à
l'extérieur situait à une distance
suffisante
il ya assez peu de risques de se faire
contaminer et donc donc on n'aura pas
sur les plates devenir fou arrête là ça
me rend fou une technique de d'isoler et
vraie notre hassen qui a été beaucoup
plus efficace c'est à dire que si la
personne ce qui excusez moi mais je ne
vous parle pas juste alors les terrasses
on aurait dû laisser ouvert et oui mais
la fin mai mais à mon avis oui le
problème la difficulté l'arrivée des
chiffres c'est que moi je vois les
troquets qui sont ouverts
1 les mecs ils sont dans l'entrée ils
sont à 20 centimètres l'un de l'autre et
il reste il reste c'est saône est en
train de se parler de s'envoyer des
postillons dans la tronche sur le mur
mais mais mais mais l'atout - c'est ça
qui est c'est ça qui est grave c'est que
quand tu laisses et terrasses ouvertes
les gens ne respectent pas les médias et
la réalisation elle est contagieuse
regardez oui à 65% non à 35%